Eine Mikrowelle
hat fast jeder zu Hause.
Aber kann man dem Teil trauen?
Nein! Genau das
werden wir herausfinden.
Und zwar jetzt.
(Titelmelodie)
Okay, Freude der Sonne,
um zu verstehen, was die Mikrowelle
mit unserem Essen anstellt,
müssen wir zuerst verstehen,
was Mikrowellen sind.
Mikrowellen sind
elektromagnetische Strahlung.
Wir werden ständig von elektro-
magnetischer Strahlung bestrahlt.
Z.B. durch die Sonne.
Wenn ihr mein Video
über Farben gesehen habt,
wisst ihr, Licht
ist elektromagnetische Strahlung.
Die gibt es in allen
möglichen Wellenlängen.
Röntgenstrahlen,
Radiowellen, UV-Strahlen ...
Lasst uns das hier vertiefen.
Denn Wellenlänge ist eine
wichtige Eigenschaft von Strahlung.
Also, was heißt Wellenlänge?
Das hier ist eine große Wellenlänge.
Und das hier eine kleine Wellenlänge.
Man kann auch sagen:
Das ist eine niedrige Frequenz.
Und das ist eine hohe Frequenz.
Wenn wir Farben sehen,
ist es nichts anderes
als elektromagnetische Strahlung,
die auf unsere Netzhaut fällt.
Dabei ist rotes Licht längerwellig,
blaues Licht kürzerwellig.
Dieses sichtbare Licht
hat einen Wellenlängenbereich
von ein paar 100 Nanometer.
Doch das elektromagnetische Spektrum
ist viel breiter.
Es gibt Wellenlängen
im Pikometerbereich
und Wellenlängen im Kilometerbereich.
Es gilt: Je kürzer die Wellenlänge,
oder je höher die Frequenz,
desto energiereicher die Strahlung.
Energiereich kann problematisch sein.
Am kurzwelligen Ende des Spektrums
haben wir z.B. Röntgenstrahlung,
mit Wellenlängen
von unter 10 Nanometern.
Röntgenwellen sind so energiereich,
dass sie z.B. Elektronen
aus Atomen rausschlagen können.
Sie gehören zur
"ionisierenden Strahlung".
Und können Zellen und DNA schädigen.
Auch die längerwellige UV-Strahlung
gehört zur ionisierenden Strahlung.
Weswegen zu viel Sonne
auch nicht gesund ist. Wisst ihr ja.
Ab dem Wellenlängenbereich
des sichtbaren Lichts,
also ab 400 Nanometern,
ist elektromagnetische Strahlung
nicht mehr ionisierend,
kann also auch keine
molekularen Schäden mehr hervorrufen.
Mikrowellen sind
auch nichtionisierend.
Der Mikrowellenherd in der Küche
arbeitet mit Strahlung
im Wellenlängenbereich von ca. 12 cm.
Also deutlich längerwellig
als sichtbares Licht
und damit auch deutlich energieärmer.
Aber, Wellenlänge und Frequenz
sind nicht alles.
Es gibt auch noch die Amplitude.
Eine Welle kann bei
gleicher Wellenlänge und Frequenz
unterschiedlich
hohe Amplituden haben.
Je höher die Amplitude,
desto intensiver ist die Strahlung.
Intensität
ist physikalisch gesprochen
Leistung oder Power pro Fläche.
Wie viel Power
so ein Mikrowellenherd hat,
verraten uns die Wattzahlen.
Bzw. auf neuen Mikrowellen
steht ja nicht mehr Watt drauf,
sondern so komische
Fisch, Fleisch, Kartoffeln.
Macht alles kompliziert.
Ich schweife ab.
Mikrowellenherde operieren
bei Leistungen von 150-900 Watt.
Damit kann man Essen erwärmen.
WLAN-Router allerdings,
die auch Mikrowellen ausstrahlen,
und zwar in einer ganz
ähnlichen Frequenz, 2,4 GHz,
sind auf 0,1 Watt beschränkt.
Also, rund 1000-
bis 10.000-fach schwächer.
Deshalb kann man auf einem WLAN
Router trotz passender Frequenz
keine Essensreste aufwärmen.
Doch warum wird Essen
in der Mikrowelle überhaupt heiß?
Nehmen wir ein Wassermolekül, H20.
Das O-Atom zieht stärker Elektronen
zu sich, so entsteht am O-Atom
ein negativer Ladungsüberschuss,
an den H-Atomen
ein positiver Ladungsüberschuss,
man sagt auch,
das H20-Molekül ist polar.
Im elektrischen Feld orientieren
sich die polaren Wassermoleküle
der Ladung entsprechend.
Elektromagnetische Wellen
wirken auch wie elektrische Felder.
Nur, dass Plus und Minus
ständig wechseln.
Man sagt: das Feld oszilliert.
Mikrowellen sind jetzt genau
in der richtigen Größenordnung,
um mit Wassermolekülen
zu interagieren.
Durch das oszillierende Feld
richten sich die Wassermoleküle
ganz schnell abwechselnd aus,
und fangen an, sich zu drehen.
Durch das Drehen und auch durch
das Aneinanderreiben von Molekülen
entsteht Hitze.
Das ganze funktioniert auch
mit anderen polaren Molekülen,
wie z.B. Zucker oder Fetten.
Nur nicht ganz so gut
wie mit dem Wasser,
denn Fettmoleküle sind lange
Moleküle, die nicht so klein und
beweglich sind wie Wassermoleküle.
Übrigens ist Temperatur
nichts anderes als
die Bewegung von Molekülen.
Das heißt, auch wenn ich Essen
in einem Topf erhitze,
bringe ich meine Essensmoleküle dazu,
sich schneller zu bewegen.
Also, was heißt das jetzt
für Behauptungen wie:
"Mikrowellen verstrahlen das Essen"?
Mikrowellen sind nicht-
ionisierende Strahlung.
Die ist physikalisch
gar nicht dazu in der Lage,
Atome oder Moleküle zu verändern und
dadurch Zellen oder DNA zu schädigen.
Das kann nur ionisierende Strahlung
wie Gamma-, Röntgen-
und UV-Strahlung.
Stattdessen bringen Mikrowellen
einfach nur Moleküle zum Drehen.
Dabei entsteht Hitze
und dabei passiert auch
nicht viel anderes
als bei anderen Arten der Erhitzung.
Die Befürchtung,
das Essen zu verstrahlen,
muss man also nicht haben!
Und übrigens: Dieses Ding
hier ist kein Strahlenschutz,
sondern einfach nur ein Spritzschutz.
Wenn Plastik
vor Mikrowellen schützen würde,
dann würde sich auch
das Essen nicht erwärmen.
Okay, aber warum wird auf Babynahrung
so oft vor Mikrowellen gewarnt?
Hier kommen wir zu einem klaren
Nachteil von Mikrowellen.
Mikrowellen erhitzen ungleichmäßig.
Das liegt vor allem an dem Aufbau
von Mikrowellenherden. Wenn ihr
in euren Mikrowellenherd reinschaut,
dann seht ihr, dass das Teil
mit Metall ausgekleidet ist.
Aber, nur weil eine Mikrowelle
zum großen Teil aus Metall besteht,
solltet ihr kein Metall
in die Mikrowelle reintun.
Wisst ihr bestimmt.
Vor allem geknitterte Alufolie
oder spitze Ecken wie
bei Gabeln können zu Funken,
Überhitzung und Zerstörung
der Mikrowelle führen.
Das nur als kleiner Sicherheits-
einschub. Zurück zur Frage,
warum die Metallwände dazu führen,
dass das Essen ungleich erhitzt wird.
Die Metallwände
reflektieren die Mikrowellen.
Auch die Tür reflektiert, sie ist
mit einem Metallgitter versehen.
Die Löcher sind deutlich kleiner
als die Wellenlänge der Mikrowellen.
Sichtbares Licht kommt da durch,
weswegen wir auch sehen können,
was in der Mikrowelle los ist.
Auf die langwelligen Mikrowellen
wirkt das Gitter
wie eine geschlossene Metallwand.
Genau wie ich nicht
in ein Bodengitter reinfalle,
solange die Gitterlöcher
kleiner sind als meine Füße.
Durch diesen faradayschen Käfig,
so nennt man das,
bleiben die Mikrowellen
im Inneren der Kiste,
was ja auch schön ist,
weil wir draußen ja nicht
mitgekocht werden wollen.
Die Mikrowellen werden also im Inne-
ren reflektiert und überlagern sich.
Und dabei entstehen stehende Wellen.
Stehende Wellen kann man auch
mit einem normalen Seil herstellen.
Da gibt es schöne YouTube-Videos.
Und da seht ihr: Stehende Wellen
haben fixe Knotenpunkte.
Und Maximalppunkte. In der Mikrowelle
sieht es dann so aus:
An den Knotenpunkten
haben wir kalte Stellen,
an den Maximalpunkten heiße Stellen.
Wir haben keine ebenmäßige Erhitzung.
Deshalb auch die Drehscheibe.
Und hinzu kommt ja noch,
dass Wasser zwar gut erhitzt wird,
aber Fett zum Beispiel weniger gut.
Und auch das führt zu ungleich-
mäßiger Temperaturverteilung.
Besonders tricky ist, wenn ich
Essen in der Mikrowelle warmmache,
dann ist das Essen nicht einfach
außen am heißesten,
wie bei einem Ofen. Sondern,
es ist eine totale Surprise,
wo ich mir da drin
meine Zunge verbrenne.
Deswegen auch:
Vorsicht bei Babynahrung.
Doch neben der Überhitzung gibt es
noch ein Problem mit Mikrowellen:
Je nach Bakterium empfiehlt sich
eine Erhitzung auf mindestens 60-70°.
Da wir in der Mikrowelle
überall kalte Flecken haben,
da, wo die Knotenpunkte sind,
werden da natürlich
auch keine Bakterien abgetötet.
Deswegen sollte man in Mikrowellen
auch kein rohes Fleisch kochen.
Mal abgesehen vom Geschmack.
Auch wenn normal gekochtes Essen
immer wieder
in der Mikrowelle aufgewärmt wird,
steigt das Risiko
für eine Verunreinigung durch Keime.
Deshalb beim Wiederaufwärmen
mit der Mikrowelle immer wieder
zwischendrin umrühren
und darauf achten,
dass wirklich alles heiß wird.
Das heißt,
Mikrowellen sind nicht zu empfehlen,
wenn man etwas richtig
ordentlich durchkochen möchte.
Und auch nicht, wenn man etwas sehr
schonend nur erwärmen möchte.
Einfach weil man über die Temperatur
keine besonders gute Kontrolle hat.
Bleibt nur noch die letzte Frage:
Wie gesagt, molekulare Veränderungen
durch Strahlung ist bei Mikrowellen
nicht drin.
Aber, natürlich verändert erhitzen
so manche chemische Struktur.
Ich meine,
kochen ist halt auch nur Chemie.
Ob Vitamine, Antioxidantien und Co.
durch erhitzen kaputtgehen,
dazu gibt es ein altes Video von uns.
Schaut euch das gerne an,
aber die kurze Antwort ist:
Es kommt aufs Lebensmittel an.
Manche Sachen,
wie Vitamin C zum Beispiel,
gehen bei Hitze tatsächlich kaputt.
Andere wertvolle Nährstoffe
sind durch Hitze leichter zugänglich,
weil dadurch zum Beispiel
schwerverdauliche Cellulose-
fasern zersetzt werden.
Wenn man jetzt Gemüse
in der Mikrowelle zubereitet,
dann hat man
bei ungleichmäßiger Erhitzung
natürlich auch
beide Effekte gleichzeitig.
Doch meistens wärmt man
in der Mikrowelle ja sowieso nur
bereits gekochtes Essen auf.
Das gilt auch für die
meisten Fertig-Mikrowellengerichte.
Es gibt sogar einige Studien
aus der Lebensmittelchemie,
die verschiedene Arten
des Erhitzens untersucht haben.
Verlinke ich Euch. Aber, da
gibt es auch keinen Hinweis darauf,
dass Mikrowellenzubereitung generell
schlechter für Nährstoffe ist.
Die lustigste Studie,
zumindest für die Freunde der Sonne,
die diesen Kanal schon länger
schauen, ist diese Studie über Tee.
Grüner Tee
enthält Moleküle namens Catechine,
die eine Reihe gesundheitsför-
derlicher Eigenschaften haben sollen.
Und, die man durch das Brühren
in heißen Wasser extrahiert.
Wenn man aus dem grünen Tee maximal
viele Catechine rausholen möchte,
empfehlen die Forscher
"eine halbe Minute ziehen
im kochenden Wasser".
Gefolgt von einer
"einminütigen Mikrowellenbehandlung".
Wohlgemerkt schmeckt das Ganze
nicht ganz so gut,
weil Catechine ziemlich bitter sind.
Insofern: Danke für die Info!?
Damit sind hoffentlich
die wichtigsten Fragen
zu Mikrowellenessen geklärt.
Und ich kann jetzt endlich
über die heutigen Mikrowellen randen.
Jetzt mal ganz ernst:
Gibt es irgendjemanden,
der diesen ganzen Zirkus hier
besser findet
als nur zwei Rädchen
mit Watt und Zeit?
Was sollen
diese automatischen Programme?
Gemüse? Fisch? Fleisch? Nudeln?
Wo ist Reis?
Wo kann man die Leistung einstellen?
Das habe ich bis heute
nicht herausgefunden.
Untertitel:
ARD Text im Auftrag von Funk (2019)